[Music]
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
home is where the heart is
[Music]
a constant guest is never welcome
[Music]
a fool in his money are soon parted
[Music]
the greater the danger the greater the
honor
take no notice of the stupid things
people say
when one is hungry everything tastes
good hunger is good seasoning
look after the pennies and the pounds
will look after themselves
whom the God's love dies Young
never spend your money before you have
it
as soon as one goes out the window
another one comes in the door
every dog has its day
[Music]
a good payer will not object to leaving
a deposit
[Music]
two in distress makes sorrow less
[Music]
at the game's end we shall see who gains
[Music]
it never rains it pours
we must live by the living not by the
Dead
half a loaf is better than no bread
[Music]
of all pains the greatest pain is to
love but love in vain
old friends old wine and old gold are
the best
[Music]
let bygones be bygones
each his own God is watching over
everyone
each person knows where problems lie
a few germs never hurt anyone
when good cheer is lacking our friends
will be packing
appetite comes with eating
patients time and money accommodate all
things
[Music]
little strokes fell Great Oaks
A change is as good as a rest
to air is human to forgive divine
foreign
[Music]
a soft answer turneth away Wrath
when drums beat laws are silent
do what is right Come What May
I don't care what people say as long as
I get what I want
a Miss is as good as a mile
we're all a little crazy in one way or
another
[Music]
make the best of a bad bargain
all of us have been fools once in our
lives
you can judge a man by the company he
keeps
foreign
birth is important but breeding is more
important
God sends cold after clothes
there's no smoke without fire
poverty breeds discontent
Love Will Find A Way
foreign
people need A Home of Their Own
money goes where money is
[Music]
nothing succeeds like success
it's no crime to steal from a thief
[Music]